I have to say this I was blessed with an
absolutely great crew the cameraman Owen
royzman who couldn't be here tonight
thanks mom
Owen this was Owens first picture and I
think his third picture was the Exorcist
which is totally different in style and
he would he's just he's long retired but
a great cinematographer and then the
camera operator was a guy named Ricky
Bravo
and we were Ricky had photographed the
Cuban Revolution I was gonna say he's a
documentary he photographed the Cuban
Revolution at Castro's side and then
when from the Sierra Maestra mountains
down into Havana and then when he when
the revolution settled in he became
disillusioned and moved to Florida and
then New York and Owen found him and the
reason the film looks like the like it
does is because Ricky could hold the
camera in his hands and go anywhere we
never laid dolly tracks you know it's
all hand held sometimes we push him in a
wheelchair you know they didn't have the
the famous Steadicam many of you know
what a Steadicam is don't you or do you
you know it's a thing that it's a
gyroscopic gizmo that straps around the
camera operator that keeps the camera
steady we didn't have that so there's a
little bit of a shake every once in a
while that was never intended III watch
films now and I see that that's done
intentionally but in the French
Connection he just held the shots as
smoothly as he could under the
circumstances
so it's just it just a couple of
questions about the score I noticed
tonight and I and I don't know if this
was intentional or not that the drill
that was being used to
the rocker panels out of the car sounded
suspiciously like the horns of the score
and the rest of the movie yeah I think
Don Ellis based his score a lot on the
sounds that he heard from the film but
I'll tell you about that but the guy who
takes the car apart in that scene was a
man named Irv Abrams and he was the
actual guy in the police garage who took
the car apart in the actual case so and
and they put it back together in six
hours and he did he just showed me while
we had the camera running what he did
and that's exactly what happened until
Scheider said how much did the car away
and it on the sheet when they checked it
in it was a hundred and twenty pounds
more than it should have been and so
then herve Abrams said at that point he
thought what have I not opened up here
and he he thought only those rocker
panels that's where they in the actual
case this is exactly how they brought
thirty two million dollars worth of
heroin in and they would take the money
back to France in one of those cars they
bought at an auction but Irv Abrams was
the guy who did it in the film and in
real life the score was written it was
the first score a lot of people this was
their first film the editor jerry
greenberg
a wonderful editor that was his first
film as an editor and the score was done
by a guy named Don Ellis do any of you
know who Don Ellis was I hope so he was
one of the great jazz trumpeters of my
time he was in his 20s he died in his
30s and he used to play at a club on
Melrose called nucleus nuance and my
nights was devoted to his band which was
called a rehearsal band they weren't
getting paid except what they got from
people who came in to the club to hear
this band play on Monday night and he
played incredible time signatures that I
I've never heard before in jazz or even
in classical music and every instrument
in his band was electrified he had
electric trumpets before anyone else
before Miles Davis and electric drums
all the horns were electric everything
and I used to go there on Monday nights
and and listen to this incredible music
and shortly before we got the go-ahead
to make the film which was after two
years that the film had been turned down
by every studio for two years some of
them turned it down twice before dick
zanuck at 20th Century Fox said that he
would make it but he told us I don't
know why I just have a hunch about this
he said you guys better shoot it fast
because I'm gonna get fired over here
and he was fired before we started
shooting by his father and anyway when I
got to go ahead I went to Don Ellis on a
Monday night and I asked him if he'd
like to do a score for a film and he
said yeah why not
and this was his first score it's it's
very far out it's really extraordinary
music and the studio did not like this
quartet the studio didn't like to score
the head of music there was a guy named
Lionel Newman part of the great musical
Newman family which included Alfred
Newman the great composer and then Randy
Newman of course but Lionel Newman was
head of music and he came to the scoring
sessions when Don was playing this stuff
and he said I don't understand this crap
you
can't put this into the picture he said
you're Hawking up there on the screen
and he's Hawking over there with his
music you're both Hawking and he said
you don't want to have everybody
connected with the movie be Hawking I
understood what he meant but but to me
this this wasn't Hawking this was really
interesting stuff and but also
throughout the film there are a lot of
key moments where you use absolutely no
score whatsoever I mean the score is
used very specifically and very
sparingly there's no score and the chase
I try not to use score whenever possible
and I used more of this score than
perhaps I should have but just because I
liked it I was a fan I don't think
anybody's complaining well the opening
is pretty loud you know I expected a lot
of people to head for the exits and and
for their TV sets